welcome back well we've heard a pretty
extensive range of opinions on today's
show so let's finish with somebody who
is firmly behind the prime minister's
deal the Conservative Party Chairman
Brandon Lewis now thanks very much for
being on the show
Roger good morning this morning well
it's not long now until this vote is it
and around 100 Conservative MPs say that
they don't like to read somebody's deal
it looks like it's gonna be really hard
to get that through power but so what's
plan B
well actually plan B is plan a it's to
get this deal agreed it is the only deal
that's there on the table it's the only
option we've got if this deal doesn't go
through we have the risk of no brexit No
Deal potentially and labor soar Kier
just a few minutes ago arguing for a
second referendum effectively again
there's a whole range of chaos that can
come through whether this is a deal that
delivers on the referendum and does so
in a way that's good for our economy so
our focus over the next week and my
folks as well as my colleagues will be
on working with colleagues talking to
colleagues we've got a lot of debates
over the next few days where Cruz could
see the detail talk through the detail
and I hope when they come to that vote
on December the 11th that they vote for
the deal see I can't work out if you
actually don't have a plan B or if you
really do have a plan B but you just
don't want to tone about it which one is
it look the reality is we've got this
vote on December the 11th we are
focusing everything on doing what is
right for the country and that is
getting this deal through that delivers
on as Nick mentioned earlier is
important in my constituency and others
around the country the end of free
movement the end of the Common
Agricultural Fisheries Policy the end of
all that money going to Europe Alec
County for the end of the direct
jurisdiction of the ECJ but also doing
it in a way that's good for our economy
the ability to do those trade deals so
it is the right deal to go for and the
reality is if you look at the makeup of
palm listen to what Kirsten was saying
earlier today what we hear from
opposition benches and others in
Parliament when this is discussed
actually there is people pushing for a
second referendum people pushing for no
brexit at all as well as no deal so the
real the real option for us is to get
this deal through that gives stability
it gives certainty and allows people to
get us as a government back onto
focusing on the domestic issues that
people care about I think you
acknowledge that that it's going to be
chaotic if you don't get in a deal
through we know
numbers are looking really difficult I
think people would like the reassurance
of knowing that you have got a plan I
mean look we'll make it don't have to
tell me what the plan is you know you
don't have to go into the detail I
understand if you don't want to say
anything but have you actually got a
plan B as I said Plan B's plan a we've
got to get this deal through because it
is the deal that delivers on what people
want and actually though I go
campaigning about her Tina majorly I
don't know quite sure where she's been
but I go all over the country every week
we've got people out knocking on door
steps every week what people at home
tend to want to talk about is the things
that affect them every day whether it's
there being collections the local school
good NHS a chance for a good job
tomorrow I want the Conservative Party
the government to be able to get back to
focus on those issues and to do that
having delivered on what people voted
for in 2016 this deal does that and it
is let's be frank again it's the only
deal that is out this the only deal
coming from EU it's the only deal that
delivers to this country well I think
that's probably a lot of us who we don't
identify as bobble board of thing rights
and we heard the case Talmud say earlier
that if the deal doesn't go through
Parliament is inevitable that they're
going to move and no-confidence motion
is that something you're preparing for
well I say I think we saw early on today
in the interview with yourself that Kier
was very open about the fact that they
want Labour's whole aim is to frustrate
breaks it they came out with these six
things they wanted to see this deal
effectively does to live on that and he
does it in a really positive way and yet
Labour's still argued not to support
this and that's because they do want
this chaos they want to try and bring
the government down to disrupt the
country and to disrupt brixi and what
was very clear let me just finish the
point at she which is a Kia's core point
at the end of that that he kept coming
back to as John MacDonald has done is
this desire for a second referendum and
that's again why getting this deal fur I
think is so important so it does deliver
on brexit for people so just to bring
you back to and the no-confidence motion
is that something that you're prepared
if Labour put a no-confidence motion
that is saying we will have to deal with
actually the best way to prevent that is
to get this deal through Parliament on
December the 11th it's pretty clear that
that's the plan a to get the deal
through and other people in your party
though are looking at Plan B's and Nick
Bowles we heard from one of them earlier
he said he is going to support the Prime
Minister's deal but he's just looking at
what
happens if it doesn't go through and
this idea of a Norway plus option where
the UK will be staying in the single
market I mean is that something that you
think could work I don't think the
Norway option works that Nick's a great
collies a good friend I worked with him
in a department together for a long time
and he said you've got a brilliant mind
the problem though with the Norway
option which he did to be fair and
knowledge in that interview you did with
him is that for a lot of people in this
country one of the core reasons they
voted to leave near you isn't dealt with
in the Norway model and that's the end
of free movement
it also doesn't stop the continual
payments to the EU something else people
feel strongly about so Norway isn't the
world ocean and again I'll come back to
a very key fact it's not on a table the
thing is he admits that as well as you
say in the interview but he says that
the other option could be No Deal which
in his being would be like Thelma and
Louise driving off a cliff I mean it
surely as a responsible government it's
only right to look at other things that
could avert chaos well none of us wants
sea cows I think a no do is a bad thing
for the country also I think no bricks
is bad for the country and bad for
democracy after that vote and I think
what people want to know is that as
their government we're focused on being
ready for doses we've said for a while
we've been planning for no deal we don't
want it we don't think it's where we
should be and where we need to be we
have to be ready for that but the
reality is I think most people want us
focused on delivering a good deal for
the United Kingdom that delivers on the
referendum in a way that's good for our
economy and I think people when they
look at this will want to know their
government's focus is entirely based on
getting that good and the right deal
approved through Parliament a few
debating days nine days five days of
debates roughly to go through and have
that discussion and I hope as colleagues
go through those debates look at the
detail of this listen to the Argos and
important your Monday listen to the
Attorney General as well I hope on
December 11th we'll get this deal
approved and are you ready for an
election I'm ready for the nine 2019 Lok
elections that's got a mine we will be
ready for 2022 GM election look I don't
think anybody watching this programme
have heard to general elections and a
referendum in the last three years he's
looking for another generation or paying
the government for that I'm not looking
at a general election I'm looking to get
this deal through on December 11th well
I'm planning for the 2019 local Asians
not for Jim election I don't think
that's where Parliament is are doping us
where the country is I think they want
us to see us as
government and as a parliament getting
on with this getting this job done and
getting back to folks on domestic issues
that help people everyday and another
round brewing over brexit is about the
illegal abayas
why is the government not publishing the
full legal advice or brexit what would
you say scared of well I think there's a
you know it's a historic centuries I
think old custom in this country and
proper legal precedent that that client
confidentiality between lawyers we have
to give advice to clients where there's
the governor or anything else that's an
important part of our Constitution in
the way the government works when we saw
that through the Iraq war with labor as
well however this is an unprecedented
situation and that's why we've got an
unprecedented situation just tomorrow
where the Attorney General will be
making statement to Parliament and I
would hope again that when colleagues
hear what the Attorney General has to
say they'll be satisfied that the
governor has delivered what it said he
would do on that vote a couple of weeks
ago okay now on a slightly different
matter you mentioned immigration earlier
on earth for many people that was you
know that the main reason that they
voted to leave in that referendum now
you point out remember you came on the
show around a year ago when you were in
the grocery Minister and have a look
what you said about the immigration
white paper we will publish our
immigration bill and our white paper
pretty soon actually it'll be early next
year now that was back in December 2017
it's still not been published what's
happening well what's happened I mean
Louis it's always good to come back and
a show on an anniversary to be able to
talk and I see I mean we will be talking
about immigration during the course of
this week actually in these debates and
the realities as this negotiation the EU
has developed what became very clear is
the immigration bill is about setting
out that outline of what our immigration
policies will be now we outline that our
part of conference this year the legal
requirement to do that is to have that
framework in place the legal power to
set our immigration laws when we leave
the European Union and shortly after I
mean literally I think about a week or
so after I was on the show and said that
last year we got that agreement with the
EU around EU citizens rights which was
potentially part of that we've also
since then of course got the
implementation period agreed which means
your new immigration laws won't come
into place until 2021 and therefore
Parliament doesn't need yet look at that
immigration bill because it still got 18
months to two years
where it comes into force so policy
focused on its two-and-a-half-year on
referendum momentum people send a very
very clear message about immigration and
we still don't really know what the
government's strategy is well I disagree
you know disagree on that so if you look
what what the bill is about and is
setting out the framework the legal
power for us to set immigration rules
against EU countries which is a moment
we don't have so that some we've
outlined and said we're going to do and
that has to be in place for when we
leave the EU which is after that
implementation period so parliaments we
focus on the legislation a time wise it
needs to do in order to prepare to leave
that the immigrations paper comes for
2021 in terms of its delivery but we
have outlined what we want our future
policy to be there'll be more details
coming through shortly but we outlined
at a party Commerce and we want to move
to an immigration system that is about
skills making sure we have access to the
skills this country needs so the people
can come here based on the skills
they've got rather than based on their
geography I like that he's a very
clearly when are we going to get this
white paper is it going to be before the
end of the year I think you'll see the
van white paper very soon we'll be out a
little bit well I'm not gonna be tempted
to tie the hands the home century I
think he's right he comes forward with
that white paper when he's ready to
outline that in line with where we are
in terms of not just the negotiations
but the legislation for when we're ready
to leave you and as I say the new
immigration rules now don't come into
place until 2021 that something has
changed since that original quote okay
Brenda Lewis thank you very much